[Music]
good to have you here John yeah okay
well I don't know why you're doing that
that's that's awful don't like I hate
when people who did it yeah that was the
worst welcome to the show nice to see
you I'm I'm sorry are you Barry are you
wearing a Breathe Right strip on your
nose I'm wearing a Breathe Right strip
let's get a real let's go real close on
that guy's go tight
let's go tight all right I woke up this
tighter just go for it
okay go in my nose gotta left hands get
it right yeah yeah okay I think we've
confirmed it is a breathe and they got a
big one I woke up this morning just had
a real stuffy nose and I felt like let
me just do this I want to perform at my
peak and you know there is just I flew
to LA I wanted to not cancel this
because of a stuffed nose mhm
and there's an old saying in showbiz you
know get er done no no that's not an old
saying in show business
that's the ya know you're thinking of
the show must go on that's what you're
thinking of that's not the one I was
thinking of that is also good one but I
wanted to make sure I could get get er
done no yeah I don't know what I hate
worse this or the get er done so you're
doing let's call it a tie oh yeah it's
an evening tie all right well you enjoy
your sippy drink there let me ask you we
we go back a ways we know each other I
want to know how your family is let's
let's get personal how are your kids
doing my kids doing good my son will be
six next month yeah go for the applause
you've got to stop that I I agree with
you he's six and we had a very sweet
moment very funny moment reached on
where I was in the shower he came in the
bathroom and I was getting out and he
said daddy you have a penis and I said
yeah just like you right and he said
it's so giant now just to be clear I'm
not telling this story is a really cheap
way to brag about the size of my penis
I'll just say full disclosure it's not
giant it's pretty good though right it's
pretty decent gets the job done it gets
her done
[Applause]
it was so very just you know genuine
just innocuous sweet moment and it kind
of gave me an idea for a TV show much
along the lines of the old kids say the
darndest things yes old art Linkletter
shows things yeah my show is gonna be
called my son says the darndest things
dot dot dot about money
[Laughter]
yeah that'll run that'll run for a year
or a horrible you're a horrible guy get
some dad though
[Laughter]